new updates in the Idaho College student
murders case one of the surviving
roommates has now agreed to an interview
with Brian coburger's defense team after
fighting to stay out of the proceedings
21 year old Bethany Funk lived in the
same off-campus home where Madison Mogan
Zana kernodle Kaylee Gonzalez and Ethan
Chapin were all brutally stabbed to
death in November this week we learned
that the surviving roommate will meet
with lawyers from suspect Brian
coburger's defense team at her home in
Reno Nevada according to court documents
funk's lawyers initially argued against
their client testifying at the June
preliminary hearing or even during a
trial but in new filings on Wednesday
both sides have agreed to the defense's
interview in order to dismiss Funk
subpoena depending on the information
that funk gives investigators she could
ultimately skip out of that preliminary
hearing so let's talk about what this
means Terry a lot of evidence against
Brian coburger at this point what do you
think it will be what do you think this
is going to be for the overall defense
strategy I think the number one thing he
is going to say is listen it wasn't me
you have the wrong person here and he's
going to go through all the evidence
that they have so far and what do they
have they have the car he's going to say
I wasn't driving that car they have DNA
evidence on that sheath he's going to
say that wasn't my evidence it doesn't
mean that I did it and you know that
that is possible we've seen it before in
other trials to it the O.J Simpson case
he's going to say that he wasn't
described properly we know DM gave a
description and now I think he's going
to try to say no one else in that house
could describe him so I definitely think
that is going to be part of it and I
think he's going to point to the fact
what is the motive here why would I do
this I have no criminal record why would
I ever go and ruin my career and kill
all of these individuals and the last
thing I think that the defense is going
to do is what all of the defense
generally does and what they have to do
is to say look Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
and there our doubts here and unless the
prosecution proves this case Beyond a
reasonable doubt he could get away with
it but Brian if Funk does speak to
coburger's defense how in the end is
that going to help them at a preliminary
hearing or at a trial it's kind of two
parts Jesse first it's investigatory
whatever information that they can get
from Funk they might be able to build
upon that and go and create a better
defense for the preliminary hearing or
even the trial in the future if Funk
decides not to testify the preliminary
hearing I think she'll probably Testify
the trial I don't think she can get out
of that but they might be able to use
her statements if an investigator or
someone is there and say hey she's a
missing witness we can't get her she's
outside of our subpoena power but this
is what she told us and maybe what she
didn't hear helps in improving that
these statements as to what other people
or not survivors in the house didn't say
they heard causing some sort of question
it did it happen or did it not yeah and
it's still not clear what information
she has that might be exculpatory to
Brian coburger we're Switching gears now
to the ongoing trial of Colorado stepmom
Leticia Stout accused of killing her 11
year old stepson Gannon he was reported
missing in January of 2020 two months
later his body was found hundreds of
miles away stuffed in a suitcase under a
Florida highway the defendant reported
again and missing to police she said
that he went to a friend's house and
never came home two weeks before
gannon's body was found investigators
arrested stouk after finding blood
evidence as well as inconsistencies in
her story psychologists have interviewed
Leticia Stout multiple times over the
years completing competency evaluations
two of those experts testified on
Wednesday about those findings
mystog introduced a vampire called
Justice and she said that there was a
button in her cell that she could summon
um
Justice Jasper perhaps Patrick if I
remember correctly she says she had been
introduced to vampires when she lived in
Alaska previously
and they used to go door to door like
Jehovah's Witnesses
and
um
she didn't really offer them in any kind
of meaningful way like wasn't explaining
anything or trying to use that
information necessarily but she
certainly referenced them throughout the
interview did she tell you where she got
these names for these so-called vampires
she's talking about
um she directed me to the movie Twilight
and did you find out that these names
were from the movie Twilight or the book
series yeah involved in Twilight yeah a
few of them for sure I'm not familiar
with the series myself but I Googled um
she talked about a vampire Council and
the name of the council was taken
directly from that series and then a
couple of the names for sure came from
there as well certainly if somebody's
talking about vampires and that appears
real to them that could signify that
they're experiencing a mental illness so
I
looked further to see I'm looking for
consistency again so it was notable that
she said that she had been interfacing
with these vampire since Alaska but she
made no mention of them to the previous
evaluators and she also didn't mention
them throughout her jail stay until
several months in
we noted borderline and narcissistic
features given her history of
instability of relationships
um her history of
mood swings
um
that were
I want to say best delineated by her
public defender at that time when we
consulted with the public defender she
was the one who described an intense
reactivity of emotion to different
things that just somebody who goes from
zero to a hundred
um very quickly
we also noted her own self-report of
impulsivity
um
those were the primary features of a
borderline personality that we noted
with her in terms of narcissistic
features
she really touted her intelligence and
her abilities
and when she spoke to us about
her treatment in the jail her
expectations as it pertained to how she
would not proceed with her defense but
how attorneys should treat her there was
some notable entitlement in that that
gave us a hint that there might be some
narcissistic features in there as well
Brian putting aside the fact whether
she's Faking It or Not would stalk
having multiple personalities equal an
insanity defense yes and no if she's
faking it I would lean towards no but
even if she does have multiple
personalities uh the argument from the
bra is going to be many people
throughout the country and even the
world have multiple personalities but
they do not murder because the ultimate
question is whether or not she can
appreciate right for wrong now if she
does has multiple personalities and one
of those personalities is a six-year-old
girl who can't understand the or
appreciate right from wrong and that's
the person who murdered 11 year old
Gannon then maybe if she can prove that
but it's really about the understanding
of right for wrong not necessarily the
diagnosis or the faking the diagnosis he
has I'm glad you explained that
difference in Terry actually I want to
go to you do another I think
misconception people have because stalk
was found competent to stay on trial but
that is very different between
competency to stand trial and mental
illness that could be used as a defense
right what's the difference so you're
right Jesse a lot of people do confuse
the two compete seat to Stand Tall means
that you understand the charges that are
being brought against you and you can
help your attorney with your defense and
that was determined early on here stock
was deemed competent to stand trial she
knew and understood the charges against
her but as Brian said that mental
illness is completely different you can
have multiple mental illnesses but if
you understand the difference between
right and wrong if you have that men's
Rhea meaning that you understand that
difference you have you might be guilty
of that here I definitely think that she
could be found guilty even if she has a
mental illness and so those are the
differences and people oftentimes like
you said they do confuse the two all
right